Brian where were you in your life when
you begin thinking about making this
film shortly after one six right which I
made in 2005 and was promoting in 2006
and seven we're starting to think about
what was gonna be next and so it was
around 2007 that the idea was hatched
and in 2008 I went full-time with living
in the age of airplanes so it's been
about eight years now from when I went
full-time till now I'm just starting the
promotion the DVD and blu-ray so this
entire time it's been a full-time effort
and your last two films they were
feature-length or shorts they were it
was a feature once x-ray was featured
life I thought okay mm-hmm I was a
documentary and then this one I guess by
definition its feature because over 40
minutes is considered a feature but it's
you know relatively short because it was
for the IMAX format which they need to
turn them every hour on the hour
so it's 47 minutes which is actually the
longest tied to the longest film of its
kind they're normally more like 40
minutes so 47 we stretched it as far as
we could get as much in as possible okay
in those eight years
what challenges came up oh my gosh the
challenges was you know from day one
every part of this making of I think any
movies probably especially a documentary
very challenging for this one in
particular because it was so ambitious
unlike one one-sixth row is ambitious in
its own ways and it was my first film
which inherently it's just you know
ambitious to set out on that path but
with unlike 1:6 right that was shot in
one square mile at Van Nuys Airport and
just literally the vicinity of Van Nuys
Airport this film was shot all around
the world 95 different places 18
different countries all seven continents
and it's actually the first giant screen
film or IMAX film to shoot on all seven
continents and for a single one-off film
so Planet Earth actually has job in
seven confidence but that's episodic 10
or 11 episodes and television this is
just for 47 minutes we went all around
the world to shoot it so it was
incredibly challenging and ambitious
with logistics and the planning of
traveling everything involved getting in
and out of these countries the different
languages cultures have
interpreters and drivers and permits and
just even the equipment alone getting
permission to enter and exit countries
with all this expensive equipment always
logistical you know challenges and just
even getting permits to be where we
wanted to be alone so it's months of
planning before every single shoot I
want to get into that in just a little
bit but um I know doing some research we
saw different blogs that said you know
like most National Geographic
photographers will just shoot so many
photos hundreds maybe thousands and only
end up using a couple pictures every
shot in the film is picturesque every
one of them could be a NatGeo cover so
how much footage did you get and and did
you actually capture and then how much
did you actually end up using or forty
seven minutes I guess yeah so we shot
two hundred and sixty hours of footage
total and the movies less than an hour
it's 47 minutes so there's two hundred
and fifty nine hours of unused material
so the ratio is pretty incredible but it
just takes that many hours to really get
the best stuff and many times you're
waiting for the weather waiting all day
for a shot to happen sometimes we're
waiting come back a second day or third
day there was a couple locations where
we after three days still didn't have
the right shots to make the sequence so
we had to change our plans rebook our
flights and end up actually canceling
another location because a permit at the
next location was for one day only which
we had to miss but if we didn't push and
didn't stay at the first location then
we would never have had the sequence at
the first location so rather than be get
on an airplane knowing were absolutely
don't have it it was worth sticking
around trying to get it and then we'll
figure out the next location and I had a
future point so that sort of thing
happened more than once and it was
really you know the ratio if maybe
thirty Seconds I think on average a day
of shooting it actually makes the film
okay Wow
did you use more than one camera in the
production or was it the same camera we
had one main camera called the Alexa and
it was right when it came out and we
were very fortunate to have it because
it was the summer of 2010 and we were to
buy one because we wouldn't be able to
rent one they were very almost
impossible to get purchase or rent and
even when you rent them because we were
traveling so much and we'd be gone for
so long and these kinds of trips were to
have to extend it and come back later
than we expected that would really mess
up the whole rental situation so we
needed to buy one and owned one so we
were able to get one and then we
traveled with it exclusively for all
that time so it was like a little baby
and we had to really take care of this
thing because we only had one right I've
heard that before now about the Alexa so
assuming everything went right how much
preparation went into each shot and how
much did you factor in error and then
how much did those plans change 90% of
the time there was it was very fluid
because you know we we would have a shot
list going into every location and then
oftentimes coming out of that location
we'd have maybe we wouldn't get all
those shots maybe we would a lot of
times we'd happen upon things that we
never expected certain things would
happen or fall in our lap or new
opportunity came up which was really
exciting to always be open to those
types of things when were in these
locations so it was sort of it's really
it was mixed in terms of getting the
shots we intend to get getting other
shots and seeing opportunities that we
never saw coming and then sometimes it
was so important that we get some very
specific shots we just have to stick
around those locations for extra days to
make sure that we actually got those
shots so it was really tricky like
getting airplanes to be in the shot and
contrails going up as you saw in
different ancient civilizations all in
the same shot they're all real shots
that was important very easy to add a
little plane in the sky afterwards but
we didn't do that we didn't you know it
was important to actually show the real
world and capture actual true shots like
that airplane coming up above the
Coliseum sort of juxtaposing old and new
and so we had people you know on the
ground there like I'm playing alert we
found angles where there was actually a
pattern of planes that would come over
the top there was only two or three in a
day that would actually do it so we're
to be in the right place the right time
be rolling at the right time because you
can't see the plane where the cameras
until the plane is already into the shot
so anyway it was really you know fun but
a lot of logistics and planning and
waiting almost like nature photography
in many ways
well so that's what I'm wondering
because you know when we saw you in 2009
you had finished 1/6 right a few years
prior to that but you were starting this
but that was different because that was
sort of your baby now you have more
things on the line how stressful was
that well it's always you know making
movies is stressful for sure I was lucky
I was making this independently similar
to 1/6 right where I was able to create
the film sort of in a vacuum and then at
the end seek distribution with National
Geographic so they weren't involved
through the filming of the or the
post-production it was only at the very
end of the film so I got to make the
film I wanted to make take the time that
I wanted to take to make it the way I
envisioned it from the beginning and
then sought out distribution at the end
so it was a real luxury as a filmmaker
to have that opportunity twice now with
both of these films so going back the in
the beginning of the eight years was
that your plan all along to approach
someone like National Geographic or it
was emirates also one of the sponsors or
no they just happen to know okay but
they did a group they did a great you
know thing for one of our premieres yeah
I saw it yeah it was amazing that's why
I wasn't sure if maybe is somehow okay
and I think I saw one of the Emirates
planes yep to the Hoff right yeah so was
that your plan did you have a list of
who week you were going to approach once
it was fair I had some ideas who were
gonna approach and actually did talk to
National Geographic and some others
early on in 2007 when the idea was just
hatching but I decided against actually
going with distribution from the start
just a strategic choice because whenever
you have anyone involved what are their
financing it or going to distribute it
you're basically backing into their
timeline you're backing into their
structure formula what it might be and
then you know basically they're gonna be
involved and in some way maybe a little
maybe a lot in shaping what you're doing
and it was really important to me
because this was a incredibly passionate
idea that I had and I wanted to see it
all the way through in the purest form
possible with a single vision that I had
for telling a story to how the airplanes
changed the world just a really tricky
thesis that you can do a thousand
different ways we
really important that that would stay
pure and the only way to do that was in
fact to be as independent as possible
and to have a hundred percent creative
control and it's very difficult if not
impossible to do that with somebody
involved anybody involved from the
beginning in terms of distribution
because you need to hit the mark that
they want you to hit or the mark that
you've agreed to hit and you don't have
the flexibility inherently to go longer
to make changes to have the story evolve
potentially become maybe much better
much greater but it's different here
you're telling it different structurally
than at one point in time on paper and
it's very difficult to be able to allow
to be allowed to do that
if you have distribution in place from
day one so it's a risk for everybody to
do this as basically a spec project but
I've done it twice now and I always
worked out did you go with your DP
Andrew to every location or were there
some that you had sort of people
contracted out like Anna were you in
Antarctica yeah that's why I thought
okay Wow so you Andrew oh yeah yeah we
were I was always there anywhere you see
the camera I was right there so traveled
to a lot of places indeed so there was
never a time that you you weren't you
always made sure that the two of you
were together whoever else was right
yeah us and then a couple other people
there was the only thing that was like a
splinter unit was time-lapse photography
so a time-lapse is with a different
camera that's a special technology and a
Canon 5d basically still camera that
does time-lapse so a lot of times would
be in the same location and it was Ben
Ben Wiggins he would shoot at night and
we'd shoot the day something like that
sometimes we're shooting at the same
time in the same place and other times
we're sort of in different places and
kind of leapfrogging each other as well
so those are the only times that I'm not
with the camera is a time-lapse shot
sometimes I was there but most of the
time that was he was on a splinter unit
and were you using drones or did you use
actual real airplane for aerial
photography
yeah every aerial shots a helicopter so
yeah no drones at all actually there's
one time where there wasn't the
helicopter
an airplane in the Maldives because
there are no helicopters and the
Maldives
they were outlawed many years ago so we
had to take a door off of an airplane
one of the airplanes you see in that
sequence the blue and yellow airplanes I
had to get permission from the
government to get a door off and then we
had to basically Commission the plane
charter it with the door off and get a
waivers from the government and all this
and then that's how we did our aerial
photography in the Maldives but other
than that location every other time you
see a shot from the air it's a
helicopter
Brian I just have to ask because even
though eight years I'm sure you've lost
a lot of sleep and it was frustrating at
times it sounds really cool and I'm
pretty envious so how are you able to
forgive me for being so nosey about how
are you able to do this over eight years
yeah so I learned from 1/6 right how
important it is in the beginning to make
sure to raise enough money that's going
to see through all the way to the very
ends so because this film was so
ambitious and I knew that we were gonna
have an a-list narrator in an a-list
composer and shoot all around the world
on shoot with the best camera we'd get
her hands on and it was just gonna be an
expensive film that it was really
important to be able to have all the
money not enough money to get started or
enough money to get halfway through or
enough money to just get through
production because I've seen that happen
many many times and then you never get
to finish the film that you started or
you find yourself in all sorts of
situations where you're compromising
cutting corners this sort of thing and
that's just not in my DNA it was really
important that this realizes the full
vision of what I had first thought of
you know in an end product the only way
to do that is to be able to start only
when you have all the money secure it
and so it took a long time I took the
better part of a couple years to be able
to get that and then when we finally did
it was 2010 late 2009 early 2010 we were
finally in that position and that's when
production got underway with the film is
it playing in any other like traditional
Cineplex a--'s or will it be in museums
and Science Center's and IMAX theaters
so it's been in to date 50 different
theaters all either IMAX giant screen or
similar and Museum Science Center's some
of them are standalone IMAX theatres
like the Esquire and Sacramento
and there's one in New Zealand and you
know as East Coast all over the place
Texas Air and Space Museum in Washington
DC IMAX that's where the premiere was so
it plays mainly in those types of
theaters because it plays for months at
a time which is really cool not only is
it theatrical and a theatrical release
which is something I think every
filmmaker wishes for especially when
it's you know a spectacle in terms of
its imagery and the sort of thing but it
doesn't play in typical cinemas or
multiplex cinemas because it's a short
form film 47 minutes long it was really
designed for the every hour on the hour
Museum Science Center but multiple month
runs which is really exciting so it's
played I think 13 thousand times now for
13,000 audiences in these venues so it's
pretty pretty exciting but being on DVD
and blu-ray and iTunes now is finally
allowing everyone else to see the movie
but that don't otherwise live near one
of these places and was this something
that National Geographic secured or did
you already have that in place before
you approach them no so before I
approach the National Geographic I knew
that this was going to be where it would
play it was designed for that
specifically but I needed to find a
giant screen which is a technical term a
giant screen distributor and they out
they have those relationships so
National Geographic has a an arm of
their business that specifically
specializes in giant screen film a giant
screen distribution so they acquired
theatrical rights to do that sorry last
question um so Harrison Ford is the
perfect narrator for the film how much
time did you have to chase him down
before he read what his script was and
watched the film yeah how much time what
he was Harrison is a very avid pilot and
really passionate about aviation and has
the interest of aviation like very close
to his heart and so he he actually saw
1/6 right many many years ago and I had
since met him as a result of him seeing
that film and enjoying that film and so
he was an acquaintance for many years
and I would see him occasionally and
then
day came when I wanted to present this
new film that was under wraps for so
long that I was making that ultimately
needed a narrator and he was my first
choice and I was able to finally share
it with him but within a week of
contacting him letting him know I had a
cut with a temporary narrator I wanted
to show him for consideration to narrate
within one week of reaching out to him
he had seen the film I was able to go to
his house show him a blu-ray and he
basically on the spot said yes you know
I'm in I want to do this and he was so
committed to the whole process it was
really amazing I couldn't imagine a
better narrator for this movie